[Music]
hello everyone welcome back for another
tip 2019 interview I say this a lot but
I mean it this is an extra-special one
I'm going to explain why we are talking
about the short film thirsty right now
with JLS and Nicole Delaney so two
reasons I'll say off the top why it's a
special one is because J I love you from
escape room everyone at Collider knows
like I have a weird obsession with that
movie so we'll get that out of the way I
went to grad school with Nicole and I
really can't even begin to tell you how
excited I get when someone from our
class has a really great accomplishment
like this and then we get to support it
so being all the congratulations
congratulations thank you so thirsty for
everybody out there who has no clue what
your short film was about quick elevator
pitch what is it elevator pitch thirsty
is about a mosquito voiced by Maya
Rudolph who falls in love with a man
after she tastes his blood and he's been
recently cheated on by his girlfriend
and so after he's bitten on his private
parts he wakes up in the morning
thinking he's contracted some kind of
crazy thing because he's been cheated on
but it's really a mosquito bite and over
the course of the film he starts to hear
the the desperate longing musings of
this mosquito and then turns into a
mosquito himself I'm so curious about
your relationship with mosquitoes right
now do you look at them like fondly and
you wonder he's alive on the east coast
and I was like I am I'm fighting for you
why are you what what is this karmic
retribution that I'm getting because I
was bitten everywhere last week but it
didn't give me a higher awareness of I
think before I kill an insect an owl but
no insects were harmed in the making of
this film that's that's very very
encouraging I feel like in LA I have not
suffered a single mosquito bite and when
I spent one weekend at home in New York
Labor Day weekend like my ankles are
covered up thank you
has this changed your outlook on
I mean anytime anytime a mosquito voice
by my Rudolph bites you I mean how could
you not yeah that is life-changing
that's real love yeah it's life-changing
no I I do find myself you know letting
bugs out of the house more often not
stepping on them more often we're just
trying to create a higher awareness for
insects here it's funny I also do think
about like maybe they love us and that's
why they bite us I don't think that's
gonna care my fear of bees but I
appreciate all right just some some
information that I'm going to put in my
back pocket in case this happens because
another thing that I discovered when I
moved to LA is that there is an
overabundance of gigantic spiders what
do you do when you cross a spider how do
you get it out of the house without
killing it call my mom and you're
welcome to call her as well she can
barbecue because now I can know where
you got it from I put a glass on them
and then slide a paper under the double
cup it but at that point you run the
risk of it falling between the cracks of
the Cubs and that's very scary
especially when the spiders really high
up why are you playing with your life
like that it's so panicked I can't think
straight anymore it's awful something we
talked about uncle I die often because a
lot of the viewers out there they want
to be filmmakers too and one of the big
questions is should you go to film
school and I can never give like a broad
answer because I do think it's very very
personal but given the fact that we
graduated from the same program yeah
what is your take on that
everyone in LA I grew up in LA everyone
in LA told me not to go to film school
and of course I did it anyway but really
what film school did was it it it bought
me a chunk of time to write and create a
portfolio for myself and the other thing
that film school did is it introduced me
to people who are my rider dies people
who when I was finally ready to direct
said we're here for you
and they crewed for me and they listened
to me going crazy about the script and
consulted me on my shots and such a
strong team our film school
was repped the editor the co-writer the
producer I mean it's just it's
incredible that we have met such
supportive people that that's how what I
would recommend is just meeting other
filmmakers who are going in the trenches
with you absolutely so Jay from your
perspective having worked on this if I'm
curious to see if you name a Columbia
student who would you say is the unsung
hero of the thirsty production team yeah
JP JP a hundred percent he's a very
special dude he's very very talented you
know when you see the short aid I mean I
look amazing but the entire the entire
movie just absolutely looks amazing and
what he was able to do in creating this
mosquito was absolutely amazing in the
POV for the mosquito was was brilliant
just a really smart dude who is also
very good at improvising but never
settling or compromising quality which I
think is really important and I think
like the the film itself trying to find
the cinematic language for my point of
view and then objectively shooting him
whose you know are sort of damsel in
distress character and movie I think JB
you know we were able to find a language
that was very distinct for both
characters so you know where you are in
the story when you're with each of them
or with them together how do you get
Maya Rudolph on board to voice mosquito
I wrote on a show called big mouth and
Maya plays the hormone monstrous and it
was working on that show that I got a
real glimpse into her incredible range
as a voice artists and not to mention as
a performer as an as an actor on screen
but she is just like she's unbelievable
and my boss is at big mouth sent her a
letter that I wrote and I'd sent her the
script and you know I wrote it with the
two of them in mind so it was already
like the fact that this vision came true
is
is kind of crazy when you write a script
for actors and and yeah my and I had
lunch and she said I'm your mosquito
happy to meet did you know each other
well before this we do we met through
our friend Aaron yeah and J what is it
like for you
amassing like a resume of projects right
now because you know you have escape
room you have the Top Gun coming up and
then you pick a short film and I always
applaud that and I feel like a lot of
actors out there don't do that they go
to features and it's like features and
nothing else so is it important to you
to keep adding things like this to your
resume as you go along yeah you know
it's important I think for a lot of
reasons I think a if if it ever helps a
filmmaker in any way I am more than
willing to be there but then also like
there are a lot of voices who don't
necessarily get the hundred million
dollar platform or thirty million dollar
platform right and they are just as
talented and I want to work with them
and I love being a part of their careers
and and getting to know them and getting
to know their cinematic style and the
way they tell stories and why they tell
stories and their POV and so for me it's
always about you know there's tons of
voices to be heard and any chance I get
to be a part of that and helping some of
those voices is a lot of fun I you know
I get to bounce around a lot you know
it's obviously it's it's very fulfilling
artistically as well Shea's a
storyteller so really like you are
storytellers
so I get I see the way he thinks in the
way he's strategizing start interrupts
and the way he approaches cinema is from
that of a storyteller
and he's gonna be making his own stories
soon so it's like that I think that's
why you love directors and yeah I can
tell I love what directors love me any
directors out there it's just you know
when you guys love me it's really it's
love you know port and collaboration is
important that's one of the things I
appreciated about our program is that
like you walk in with that dream of
finding the perfect person to keep
working with
and when it actually happens it's so
special so given the fact that I think
YouTube value that quite a bit
what is just like a key asset that a
collaborator that you're about to work
with has to have what's one of the most
important things you look for someone in
your that you're about to work with
honesty and trust because I I don't
think a lot of people it's not easy to
take notes both ways right we both have
our intentions for a character we both
have our assumption of what the actors
to do the characters to do the director
should do and I think with Jay he's very
honest he's really good at communicating
but what I noticed being on set with him
was that Jay would get is so versatile
and he would I would I was I would give
about to be giving him an idea and be
like oh why don't I try at this when I'm
like you already knew what I was gonna
say before I even said it and then would
just give me things I didn't even know I
wanted and then when you have all that
in the Edit to work with all of a sudden
you have a story that's like taking on
so many different nuances because we
just wrote the thing right I have to put
a camera in front of you but then he was
able to communicate above and beyond
that was what I would yeah mine is POV -
POV and I think I am I feel safe right I
think he goes back to trust and honesty
and communication but for me it starts
with POV because if I can understand a
writer or a directors POV whether I
agree with it or not right it's not
important but if I can understand it
then I can find my way into being
comfortable into a either being able to
play or be being able to take a note
right because if I can understand your
POV even if I don't see it the same way
the fact that you have it makes me go
okay I can trust that we're at least
gonna get to that thing that you see and
that you believe right and for me when
you walk onto a set and you got a bunch
of people staring at you that you don't
know
and you have to be vulnerable you have
to open up it is a time where you really
want a safe space and knowing that
someone is getting you to a very
specific place I think for me allows me
to open up and have that freedom because
I trust them
and and I can be honest with them also
and they can be honest with me
so that's that's for me so as we wind
down here because I love those
mentalities so so much I have to always
ask what is coming up next for you first
Nicole do you want to do you want to
make another short do you want to be
writing on another show I think yeah
there's I'm hopefully making another
short this fall that would be sort of
like Brandon Zach wrote that I think
would would round out what I hope to be
my last short before kind of emerging
into the next phase which is feature
phase but I write TV I'm developing a
few shows that I'll hopefully be taking
out this fall fingers crossed
yes I feel like saying you're doing your
next project with Brandon suck is that
it's a perfect next step so it's the
best really is great and of course I
have to ask you about Top Gun a whole
lot of people out there including myself
are very excited about that movie do you
get to work a lot with Tom Cruise
I did get to work quite a bit with with
Tom it was it was amazing he's a he's a
mentor he's a filmmaker again someone
who has a very strong point of view and
can communicate it very clearly and it
allows you to be able to go out and play
and and he definitely he looked out for
us did you run him in a race by chance I
did not run him in a race nobody wants
to see the Tom Cruise right you can't
see Tom Cruise feet he's just too fast
he's so freakin bad nobody wants that
are you involved in any crazy stunts TBD
okay okay TV are you allowed to tell us
anything about your charity a to be
announced about that okay am I allowed
to tell you anything about my character
I'm a pilot okay so I may or may not fly
you slick Oh pocket that no I'll think
about it was absolutely amazing
experience a very very exciting coming
up and a very exciting thing to have
your short film premiering at TIFF you
should both be very very proud so for
everyone out there please is there gonna
be a time in the future where everyone
out there can watch thirsty one way or
the other is that the goal actually
thirsty is part of FX's new upcoming
program called cake kkkk which is like
little bite-size fun like 30-second
spots one-minute spot in ours is one of
the longer pieces of cake that's coming
out this fall Wow so yeah I love that FX
is doing that so keep an eye out thirsty
on FX again thank you so much for your
time today before we say goodbye another
thank you to our wonderful sponsor
Nordstrom Canada thank you so much for
making these interviews happen guys
this is not the last you've seen of us
at TIFF 2019 there are so many more
interviews coming to the channel so keep
an eye out like and share this one and
we'll see you soon with more coverage